I've,
I've been telling people online in
various ways and in lectures that they
should start fixing up the world by
cleaning up their room and I want it to
just elaborate on that a little bit
before I get back to the lecture itself.
So I'd say it's become this Internet
weird Internet meme,
you know,
and,
and it's a joke and good.
It's a jewel.
I really happy about the fact that so
much of this has got like the leaving of
humor and it's really important because
that's what stops things from
degenerating into,
into conflict humor.
And I was thinking about this idea of
cleaning up your room in relationship to
the mustard seed idea and you see the
thing about cleaning up your room.
This is also something I learned from
Carl young and his studies on alchemy
because for young,
when the alchemist was attempting to
make the philosopher's stone,
he was not only engaged in the
transformation of the material world,
but he was engaged in a process of self
transformation that occurred at the same
time as the,
as the chemical Trent,
as the chemical transformation.
So it was a psychological work in some
sense.
Let's say you want to sort out your room
and beautified because the beauty is
also important and let's say that all
you have is just a little room like
you're not rich,
you're poor and you don't have any
power.
That's another thing,
but you've got your damn room and you've
got this space right in front of you.
You know that,
that that's a part of the cosmos that
you can come to grips with and you might
think,
well,
what's there in front of you right in
front of you?
And the answer to that is,
it depends on how open your eyes are,
that that's the proper answer because
you could say,
w William Blake said this,
for example,
Elvis Huxley made comments that were
very similar that in a transcendent
state,
you can see infinity in the finite and
you might say,
well,
you can say,
and you can see infinity in what you
have within your grasp.
If you look and you could save,
maybe that's the case with your room,
and so you want to clean up your room.
Well,
okay,
how do you do that?
Exactly?
Well,
a room,
his room is a place to sleep and so if
you set your room up properly,
then you figure out how to sleep and
when you should sleep and how you should
sleep and then you figure out when you
should wake up and then you figure out,
well what clothes you should wear
because they have to be arranged
properly in your dresser and then you
have to have some place to put your
clothes and if you're going to have some
clothes,
you have to figure out what you're
gonna.
Wear those clothes to do.
Right,
and then that means you got to figure
out what you're going to do and then
your room has to serve that purpose
because otherwise it isn't set up
properly.
And if it doesn't set up,
if it doesn't serve your purposes,
you will be unhappy and not happy in the
room.
Because the way that we perceive the
world is as a place to move from point a
to point B in.
And then if the place that we're in
facilitates that movement,
then we're happy to be there.
And if the place that we're in serves as
an obstacle to that movement,
then we're unhappy to be there.
And so what it means to set up your room
is that you have to have somewhere to go
that's worthwhile,
or you can set up your room and your
room has to be set up to facilitate
that.
And then the next thing is,
well,
maybe you have to make it beautiful,
but that's not easy,
right?
Means you have to have some taste.
And that doesn't mean you have to have
money.
It doesn't.
Because you can be garish with money and
you can be tasteful with nothing.
All you need is taste and taste beats
money.
When it comes to beautifying things,
you know,
I mean not that money is trivial because
it's not.
But taste is crucial and people who are
very artistically oriented can make
beautiful things out of virtually
nothing.
And not only that,
the literature suggests that if you're
going to make beautiful things,
putting real constraints on,
on what you allow yourself to do,
facilitates creativity instead of
interfering with it.
Because let's say you have to make
something out of nothing,
right?
Which I suppose would be a Godly Act,
You have to make something out of
nothing.
You have to be creative in order to do
that and so then to to beautify your
room means that you also have to develop
your capacity to be creative and so then
you can make your room shine,
but then what will happen is that if
your family isn't together,
they will interfere with that.
You will interfere with that because you
won't have the discipline to do it
properly,
but then when you start building this,
this,
this little microcosm of perfection with
what you have at hand and it'll evoke
all the pathologies of everyone in your
household.
The wonder what the hell you're up to in
there and they won't necessarily be
happy because if you're.
If they're in a lowly place,
let's say,
and so are you and you're trying to move
out of that,
then the higher you move out of that,
the more the place they're in looks bad
and you might say,
well,
what they should do is celebrate your
victory over chaos and evil,
but that isn't what will happen.
What will happen instead is that they
will attempt to pull you back down.
They'll attempt to,
and I mean obviously all families don't
do that,
but,
but all families do that to some degree
and some families do almost nothing but
that.
And so what that means is that if you're
going to organize your room,
then you're going to have to confront
the devils in your house.
And that's often,
that's often a terrifying thing because
some of those devils have,
have lineages that go back many,
many,
many generations and God only knows what
you have to struggle with in order to
overcome that.
And so and then and so to sort yourself
out into fix up your room is a
nontrivial matter.
You know,
and you can do that.
You'll learn by doing that.
And then maybe you'll learn enough by
doing that so that you can fix up your
family a little bit.
And then having done that,
you'll have enough character so that
when you try to operate in the world at
your job,
or maybe in the broader social spheres,
that you will be a force for good
instead of harm.
Because you will have learned some
humility by noting just how difficult it
was to put your damn room together well
and yourself for that matter.
And so you'll proceed cautiously with
your eyes open towards the good.